[Music]
if et social study your quick look at
what the stars are posting online
Chrissy Teigen and John Legend are
enjoying a family vacation in Morocco
with their almost one-year-old daughter
Luna
oh maybe Louie the couple shared some
adorable snaps with their little one
every day is an adventure really lucky
he chose me
Hilary Duff celebrated her son Lucas
fifth birthday she posted this pic and
gushed in the caption the past five
years have been the best hardest most
blessed years of my life she makes every
day great and awesome and better and I
know myself more because of her Katie
Holmes shared this snap of her
look-alike daughter Suri smiling big
with her cousins in la-la land
Britney Spears also enjoyed a night out
in LA alongside her beau Sam Ascari the
pair hit up the Stello Fashion Show
where Sam's sister made her runway debut
meanwhile in Las Vegas the Backstreet
Boys gave in sinker Lance Bass quite an
experience
[Music]
Lance got pulled onstage during the boy
bands residency show at Planet Hollywood
what a moment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you